well after a few months or so a climate
activists will go through a phase where
they are especially annoying and
obnoxious and of course they're always
annoying and obnoxious but periodically
they will decide to be even more
annoying and obnoxious than usual it
works in Cycles like the phases of the
moon in fact the cycle might even be
tied to the phases of the moon but
that's a theory that will have to be
fleshed out another time the point is
that right now we are going through one
of the extra obnoxious periods here's
their most recent stunt from Yahoo news
it says a protester has been arrested
after just stop oil supporters through
orange paint over the headquarters of a
climate skeptic think tank in central
London climate activists from the
campaign group attacked a building in
Westminster used by the global warming
policy foundation and disrupted traffic
by sitting in the road some supporters
also glued themselves to the road and
others locked themselves together
just stop oil has been demanding the
government halt new oil and gas licenses
and consents it has been um labeled a
nuisance by many and has closed the
Dartford Crossing smeared chocolate cake
over a wax work of King Charles and
thrown various things including mashed
potato over famous pieces of Art in
recent weeks now
we'll leave aside the phrase climate
skeptic as I'm always reminding you that
there are no climate Skeptics nobody is
skeptical about the climate nobody is
walking outside looking up at the clouds
and saying I don't know about this I'm
skeptical we all agree that the climate
exists and that it changes and that
those changes sometimes result in
unfortunate weather events the
skepticism is related to the supposed
causes of those changes and the proposed
solutions for those changes indeed the
the greatest skepticism at least my
greatest skepticism as a skeptic is
directed at the notion that the weather
is a problem that can be solved At All
by anyone apart from God himself but
as I said leave all that to the side
we'll also choose not to linger on the
fact that these climate activists are
buying paint
and throwing it around even though paint
is made from fossil fuels
which is a bit like a vegan activist
purchasing 10 pounds of ground beef from
the supermarket as an act of protest
against the slaughter of cows there
seems to be a little bit of a disconnect
here a concept problem but we can't
expect these people to behave rationally
they are throwing a tantrum and if I
know anything about tantruming Toddlers
and I know a lot about them it's that
rationality is well beyond their grasp
especially in the middle of the Tantrum
the episode with the paint is just the
latest in a series of stunts stunts
which often involve throwing different
sorts of liquids onto different sorts of
objects or gluing themselves onto things
last week climate activists glued
themselves to the floor at the Porsche
Museum and the staff at the Museum did
exactly what people should be doing in
response to these sorts of things what
I've been advocating for which is that
they just closed down for the night and
they turned the lights off and the heat
off and they and they just went home and
they left the activist glued to the
floor the activists then complained that
they weren't provided food
they complained that they weren't given
buckets so that they could go potty uh
it's it's you know it's a bit like
lighting yourself on fire and and in
protest and then complaining that nobody
has a fire extinguisher on hand these
are really the sorts of preparations
that you should probably be making
yourself now elsewhere climate activists
have um blocked traffic they've run onto
the field during sporting events
and most notoriously as mentioned in the
article they've thrown various food
items onto Priceless works of art this
apparently led to um some internal
disputes among climate activists as
reported by axios with this interesting
headline headline is climate activists
divided on souping art
souping yes soup is a verb now
soup is something that you can do
because you know there are no rules in
English language as we have repeatedly
discovered the article says
quote 18 year old climate activist
Elijah McKenzie Jackson campaign
coordinator for youth climate strike
movement Fridays for future
International told axios in an email
that history tells us civil protests
like these are necessary for change
he says quote although I can recognize
these acts of Justice may seem
outrageous to people I challenge them to
feel the outrage of Destruction death
and murder all Western governments and
corporations are committing to our
animals our neighbors in the South and
our ecosystems
wrote Mackenzie Jackson 15 year old
Genesis Butler founder of global
organization youth climate save echoed
that sentiment writing in an email to
axios that quote it's important for us
all to make bold moves to raise
awareness about the climate crisis
but then there's the other side some
don't see putting fabled art at the
heart of disruptive protests as an
effective path to advancing climate
action among those who spoke out against
the van Gogh soup stunt was climate
scientist Michael Mann who criticized
the move telling the Associated Press
that people will draw negative
associations with climate active
advocacy
he's worried that they will draw those
negative associations I think it's a
little bit too late for that researchers
and journalists alike have also since
argued that these kinds of viral
activities don't mitigate climate
polluting emissions
science and policy do
oh well it's good that researchers have
made that determination I would not have
been able to figure that out otherwise
we needed researchers to tell us that
throwing tomato soup on an old painting
will not change the weather
that's what researchers are saying I
need to see the studies I haven't read
the studies for myself
I won't believe it I need to see show me
the study
that proves
you can't change the temperature outside
by throwing your food at a painting
but if soup will not alter the climate
maybe dancing will after all many
primitive cultures have believed that
dancing has some effect on the weather
and maybe they were onto something these
Healthcare professionals seem to think
so so they performed a rendition of
staying alive in Pursuit
of climate Justice let's watch this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stay alive
[Music]
[Music]
we all want to stay alive they sing
though I'm not sure I do after hearing
that I'm having flashbacks now to covid
when the nurses wouldn't stop dancing
and uh which ultimately you know did you
know covet ended up being worse than the
black plague as they predicted because
the nurses were dancing so much and back
in the black plague the healthcare
professionals they didn't do as much
dancing
I can only hope this doesn't become a
trend again because of climate change so
what is this all about
uh why are the climate activists having
these tantrums whether in musical form
or not um well one thing we must always
keep in mind is that nothing is or
entirely organic on the left there is
money behind this current rash of
activism organizations funding it and
pulling the strings
and that's especially true when you hear
about we heard in the axios article
about a 15 year old who who started an
international organization
um it's uh
almost always the case that when you
hear about it just like when the kids in
Virginia the kids in Virginia were
staging uh walkouts in their schools all
across the state because of uh you know
policies that say that only boys boys
have to use the boys room and girls have
to use the girls room then you find out
that well I know this is all being
organized by adults and by organizations
with money so the same thing goes here
but as for the grunts on the ground you
know people that are out there actually
gluing themselves to the floor or having
food fights with arctic art exhibits or
whatever else
there's not one explanation that can
suffice
for some of them this is empty virtue
signaling they're hopping on a trend
fishing for social media clout Etc
there's definitely a lot of that
and for some of them the younger ones
anyway
this is the youthful rebellious Instinct
searching for a Cause
young people naturally desire a cause to
protest over fight for or against and
climate activism provides an outlet just
it's a place to expend that energy
but underneath all of that I think
there's also nihilism this is the engine
that drives most so-called climate
activism
it's really the message that they're
sending when they destroy or attempt to
destroy a Priceless work of art or when
they block traffic randomly interfering
with people's ability to get to work and
feed their families and at the same time
creating more traffic congestion which
only causes more CO2 emissions not less
what does that achieve
well nothing of course
it is just destruction and obstruction
for its own sake
it's a protest not really against
climate change but against life Against
Humanity they are expressing their anger
at a world that to them has no meaning
they're expressing their anger at the
fact that at the fact that it has no
meaning
you know so some of these people again
the younger ones especially they really
do believe that the world is coming to
an end
they really believe it
now a lot of the a lot of the older
people the adults uh the Hollywood
celebrities that push this stuff and
they're flying around on the private
jets and Al Gore and you know we know
about all the Hypocrites behind this
stuff and they don't really believe it
they know but they're the ones who who
started this they're the ones who are
propagating the LIE
the ones propagating the LIE they know
that it's a lie
a lot of these kids don't know that
they've been told since they were
children
that the world's coming to an end
because of this
the the fear tactics the hysteria that's
all settled into their minds
but they also see no value
in life
and in the planets which they believe is
headed towards destruction
and this tension is what causes them to
lash out like they do in the way that
they do
I mean that's why it's kind of it's it's
interesting that they're going after
paintings you would think that uh if you
believed that the world was coming to an
end and that we didn't have much time
left you would cherish
beautiful art even more you know you
would have more appreciation for the
things that are beautiful in the world
but they don't because underneath all
this is nihilism lack of meaning denial
of meeting
that's what lies at the bottom of all
left-wing causes
and this one is certainly no exception
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]